hello and welcome back to Five Nights at
fredy's breaker room hard reset oh
boy oh boy okay so this one was probably
the scariest of all of these that I have
seen thus far use the megaphone on yendo
to keep them away I don't like yendo I'm
going to go ahead and say it yendo not
cool in my book oh my
God yeah it's awful
yeah it's
[Music]
awful oh I hate you so
much but I don't know if it's any worse
than what was there before and I don't
know if there's going to be any secret
mechanics so I'm just going to keep this
on me and you're not going to mess with
me be hearing things
silly stop being a silly little [__]
stay
there everything is okay let's go back
to sleep
uhhuh go back to your stage everything
is okay all right let's try
[Music]
this that had that one okay can do
that motion trigger
breaker okay the so this so the lights
do give Clues
where oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my where are you where are you oh where
are
you oh oh where where I don't see
anything oh are you over there no oh my
god oh calm down and go back to oh I see
a hand no oh my God I saw a
hand oh my God this is
terrible oh my
God oh my God oh oh my God oh my
God
oh my god oh this is awful oh my God oh
my God oh my God no one is
here it's bedtime let's go back to our
stage
huh oh my
God oh my God where Cal down I think it
was
just oh my god well that's terrible
that's awful I hate everything about
that
and I don't want to there you are let go
okay so I'm just going to get to work
cuz I need to okay this goes to get that
get
that oh boy where oh my God nope no one
is
here I got to
move that one's done where are you where
are
you
uh-huh
you must be hearing things okay now I'm
seeing
you my eyes adjusted to the darkness now
you're done
for uh let's just do in that
one oh my God I see you hold
on hold
on oh my God where are you oh go back to
your stage everything is everything is
okay let's go back to
huh where'd he go oh my God I don't know
where he
went I don't know where he
went I don't like it oh my God calm down
and go back to sleep no one is
here
okay oh calm down I think you was just
about you must be hearing things silly
uh
uh-huh oh my
God go back to your stage everything
is okay that's good that's
good that's not good where is he oh
think it's okay
hi back off back off okay you're on your
stage that's definitely doing one okay
and it's also who I see you there well I
don't like the
movement po no it's everything is okay
let's go back to sleep okay
so oh [__] oh
freck oh my
God calm down I think
to oh [__] NOP that's not good okay go
back to your stage
everything nope there we go oh where'd
you go oh where'd you go oh where'd you
go oh where' you go oh where'd you
go you must be hearing things
silly
oh oh nope no one is here
nope calm down and go back to no one is
here [__] [__] that's one oh my God hi
I'll be right with you oh my God I'll be
right with you great job just completes
your tasks for the night
hey yeah you're so strong and terrible
and awful in every way and I hate you
okay good thank you for
that uh-huh did I get yendo I sure
did yando yippe
okay
huh
interesting so this message obviously
means trash of some kind chica trash
chica head in the trash there's no trash
can here it must be in one of those
games there must be something here in
the food prep
world right that has a trash can that
would be related to that because I don't
think the message exists there no no
message that means something it's purple
and there's a trash can and there's
chica there's food so it must be in one
of the food prep levels let me just
explore that real quick let me look at
like El chips I don't think that chica
was even here usual your shift begins
now
uh-huh uh-huh no I'm not seeing anything
here let me try pizza pizza pizza
because I know that cha was there but
also there was trash in the other one
too I just need to
know was there like an easily accessible
trash can
uh-huh let's not how about we don't or
was there another game entirely that had
a trash can right wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wasn't there a
trash can in here this custom night is
just for you just for
me for me wow the mini Reas and Bey Bob
are draining the power if you see them
on any cameras shock them great be aware
of balora her music plays when she's
close great don't let the many Arenas
distract you from work toss them away
great okie dokie then
okay what what is that what is that stop
shock controlled shock who's who's
shocking me I saw
balora oh over there I forgot to look
over there right okay so someone is
still draining my
power
who's doing it oh you there you
are all right good he
hey you son of a [__] get out of here
so is balora still there I thought I saw
balora oh
oh no thank
you okay so there
was
oh ah oh [__] there you
are
uhhuh okay so this is going poorly I've
already lost a lot of power but there's
a there's a numpad
here
911 198 oh
[__] oh freak you the
bite
my so it's six it's six numbers it's six
no oh frick I did that it's six numbers
I just got to pay attention to that hi
balora how much time I got not much okay
you're spinning your way here who's
doing that you get out of
here get get out of here shock sh I
can't shock that
okay it's good to know at least I know
you're
coming nope nope sh to
[__] why this C custom night is just
for me it's just for me so if I remember
from the old FNAF days there's
definitely a code that I know very well
oh
God out
here oh you're both there get out of
here okay we're
good okay I don't know why the vent
wasn't working but it sure wasn't you
really got to come at it from a stabby
angle oh who's doing it oh I see
you
mhm
okay so my guess is there has to be
some number sequence oh I think that was
there there has to be some sequence of
numbers hey hey go down
[Music]
there hi go away
please you're still there I wonder if I
just keep chucking him down that way
okay I got to be a bit more on top of my
power or I'm going to be
doomed and I got to remember which way
is what or else I'm going to get lost
cuz it's 74 and already 1:00 a.m. I'm
not doing perfect on
power got to be a little better on the
door when I'm
okay where are
you got you oh I see you down there so I
got one coming on the
front not yet but I got to remember to
stab up from the
top it's the only way hello I see you
there there okay you're getting close
hey hey get that
way blockade
blockade bam there we go I could
probably wait a little longer is that
clear yeah okay so that clears pretty
quickly
freak okay getting better at
that okay at least Endo doesn't seem to
be too big of a problem doing slightly
better on power you're coming up okay
cool
hello how are you I'm not playing that
game
again
[Music]
okay okay I do have more time on the get
out of here oh who's sucking who's
slurping who's slurping you get out of
here
okay all right we're doing okay get what
you freaking dog piling all the vent
button really oh I'm
sorry uhhuh I like this cuz I actually
have to check the cameras that's a very
useful thing common complaint in all of
these is that you don't check the
cameras enough I just got to find out
what that code is going to be it's
probably part of the stories I will no
not there
there yeah probably part of the story so
if I get enough coins I should be able
to figure out what that is whoa you guys
are really slurping no not that where
are you God get out of here yeah I'm
still okay on power still all right well
not for
long
hello nope okay
okay okay don't know why I reached for
it again it's not like that's ever
happened to me where it bugs out and
suddenly come on they're still there on
the other
side bugs in my game impossible actually
it's kind of a thing in most FNAF games
there aren't that many bugs probably the
robustness of the engine or the
Simplicity of the engine I suppose but
yeah I've not encountered many gun and
many gamebreaking bugs get out what are
you kidding
me you freaks 500 a.m. all right we got
this couple L coming down that way
probably another
spicy Arena coming
up oh oh that's a problem okay that's
bad okay where are you where are
you so I got two coming in one down
there oh bora's gone okay so it'll be
vent come
on come
on I thought that wasn't going to happen
again all right cool all right who's
slurp you slurp all right give me 6 a.m.
I got plenty of power we're going to
make it through this and we got a six
digit code that we got to remember or
know about six digits okay got it
come on just give it to
me come on oh
god oh never mind could have saw you
coming okay that's
good I don't know if I want to enjoy
some time at home thank you very
much
oh good who wouldn't want that
chattering teeth great that's yeah yeah
oh yeah that's that's what we
want something has
changed a message for
you portal to the
Stars portal to the Stars you talk about
over
here
huh
oh yep that's
grade
uh-huh okay so purple balora are you
telling me to go to bora's Gallery cuz
there's a purple message over here with
Chica and the trash so is that talking
about the nightmare version of chica's
food
place but that might be talking about
Bora gallery which that is a fantastic
picture Funtime gang oh boy I don't know
if I want that let me just pop in here
real quick and
see if there's something that I
missed is there something for your
safety please make your way to the exit
please make your way to the exit in 5
minutes 4 3 one minute to you have to
exit is it telling me to go through this
again like beat
it is someone there
no just the tiniest
[Music]
Mouse what what
what what what what is it cuz I went too
fast all right I got to beat it just to
see if there's something that I'm
actually missing cuz I don't know if
there
is ow ow ow fine please make your way to
the exit please make your way to the
exit in 5 minutes 4 3 1 minute to exit
Okay well that's that's that's strange I
think it's cuz I'm moving just too fast
I'm just too good
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
Glam Bonnie plush oh okay unless there's
some other secret that's like in the
level and I'm going to be upset if it's
like in the level back behind where I
tried before but alas hey look at you I
can't grab you well look at you
you're not dead and decomposed forever
hello you're not dead are
you no coins for you buddy all right
well that was a waste of
time and we're going to try the carousel
again cuz that one wasn't too hard a
little technically difficult but not too
bad fix all the broken fuses then
replace any broken switches and turn on
the power
you you got it and then also watch out
for Moon some M go around broken
down uh-huh also there was a big old
fire do you remember that you going to
do anything about
that oh
[__] oh [__] how do I fix that
oh oh yeah oh oh
hi all
right oh there we
go all right all right we got our first
whoopity woo why don't I hear that
behind
me there you
are all right you go there you go there
oh need a
knob oh
boy oh I see
[Music]
you all right
where are you I see you oh
God no no no no no no no
goodbye come on oh I got to take the old
one
out where did that come from oh there
you
are you you what makes you so special I
don't know because I choose to be and I
work towards being special that's what
it is no that's not
right who did that who said that you
did yeah that's what you
get
where are
you where are you nope I see you oh oh
God oh God where are you where'd you
go where'd you go whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh
come on no
no oh okay all right we're
fine where are
you there you
are Oh I thought I saw something there
you
are
aha well there is light what are you
going to do about
it
hey
yay yippee
Wahoo ho ho I I did it wow that one was
not so
bad Okay yipp
Yahoo fascinating
[Music]
oh thank you
wow look at that they're almost all here
except for whoever's in the center not
sure who that would be definitely not a
golden Freddy or
some definitely not
that hi okay so that was another one
that we made good progress on got a few
more though Carousel is now done Faz
Cade is almost done there's more fazer
blast I can't believe
it I refuse to believe it fizzy Faz
[Music]
night let's go to Endo Warehouse prepare
endos for life in the pizza Plex
uh for Life teach the new Endo how to
behave pair the correct behaviors on the
cards if you need a hint press the hint
button don't let the other endos disturb
your lesson if they get too close use
the Faz cam to scare them
away great welcome to the playen here
young animatronic endos learn how to
associate with guests motivation chips
encourage our youth to one day develop a
personality and become the next Freddy
chica or TBD pizzaplex star think of the
staff bot in front of you as a blank
canvas uh-huh it is time for behavior
training why is it called the behavior
cards to help them understand what is
expected of them in normal everyday
human situations why is it called The
Dread under any circumstances show them
a mismatched pair to avoid potential
tragedy you will be shown the face up
cards prior to the lesson teaching is
simple just remember the cards uh-huh
class
begins okay none of these
match the is it the colors on the back
that I'm supposed to match
oh
hello okay
boy oh
boy okay okay okay okay okay oh
God oh God oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh
no I didn't do that well I didn't plan
my strategy I panicked in the face of
adversity then let that be a lesson
okay whatever okay I
know wow learn whatever that meant
congratulations you are now teaching at
a fourth grade level wow am I a fourth
grader that's great
okay got
it good job you are now teaching at a
junior high level yep oh boy okay all
right give me a
second oh boy here we
[Music]
go hold
on oh oh my God oh my God oh my God okay
let's just go for it oh [__] no that's
that was bad oh I'm freaked oh I'm
freaked
yeah sorry I I it was a misinput
oh my God
okay okay you're gone I'm going to let
you get
closer there we go okay sorry what was
it I've I've kind of Forgotten okay got
it oh that didn't
work oh wait a minute okay I'm going to
be a little better about that I'm going
to be a little better about that let's
just go straight for the memorization
and not worry about anything else in
between all right we're good come on
let's
go is that one already starting you are
now teaching at a fourth grade level
that's great Cha Cha Cha Cha
Cha come
on good job you are now teaching at a
junior high level that's
great
oh
shoot okay all right we're
good okay done you're now teaching at a
high school level that's great all
right
oh I see one over there that's fine I
missed my entire clue that's
horrible okay got
it you are now teaching at a community
college level okay good
ch
oh my God okay little more okay you're
gone congratulations yeah yeah yeah yeah
thiso is now qualified to interact with
the public smile you must be proud I am
that's a
selfie with my
boy my
boy my sweet baby boy ah Endo that's
good I hope that's not just in the hub
like with most of these things I hope
that they don't just end up in the space
cuz that would be
bad
hello no there must be a lot of coins
that I'm missing yendo what game was
yendo in can you guys tell me in the
comments what game was yendo in oh I
totally forgot about this weird thing
did you know that now if I say the word
and look look towards the description
right now scroll down a bit where where
this button is going to be if I say the
word
subscribe the subscription button will
glow I don't know if I need to say
Please Subscribe but it goes whenever I
say that I don't know if every time
subscribe hit the Subscribe button don't
forget to subscribe did you know that I
know that it's probably been around for
a bit but subscribe does it work for the
like button smash the like
button
like Thumbs Up And subscribe wonder if I
can make it just blow up subscribe
subscribe
subscri H I'm looking away I'm looking
back I'm looking okay so you don't do
anything you do a whole lot of nothing
and a little bit of a dick but that's
okay I forgive you okay so we're in a
bit of a nebula State we have some
messages we we've almost got through all
of the repair
functions yeah cuz there's that one
still locked that one's all done I
probably would get a coin if I did the
log ride better there's two locked in
staff
only nothing in food prep nothing in
backstage so we're getting close to the
end here we must be but unfortunately
I'm all out of time thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye